YOU CANNOT MAKE THIS STUFF
UP.
IF I WROTE THE MOST OBSCENE
SPY NOVEL, YOU COULDN'T MAKE
THIS UP.
THE AUTHOR OF "TRUMPED UP"
HOW CRIMINALIZATION OF
POLITICAL DIFFERENCES
ENDANGERS DEMOCRACY HARVARD
CONTRIBUTOR SARA CARTER.
TOM FITTON, SARA, BECAUSE
YOU HAVE BEEN ON THE
FOREFRONT THIS WEEK, WE NOW
KNOW THAT THE DOSSIER BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR BY HILLARY WITH
SALACIOUS LIES WAS USED TO
GET A FISA WARRANT AGAINST
--
>> -- WELL, YES, WE NOW IT
BEING ABLE TO GET THE
WARRANT TO SPY ON TRUMP AND
PEOPLE WITHIN HIS CAMPAIGN.
BUT, SEAN, WHEN YOU ARE
LOOKING AT THE DOSSIER AND I
THINK ACTUALLY LEAKING GLENN
SIMPSON' TESTIMONY ACTUALLY
BACK FIRED ON THE DEMOCRATS.
I MEAN IT REALLY DID.
YOU LOOK AT THAT TESTIMONY,
YOU SEE TO YOURSELF FIRST
GLENN SIMPSON SAID THERE WAS
A SOURCE INSIDE THE TRUMP
NOW, WHAT PEOPLE HAVE
CORRECTED THAT VERSION OF IT
AND SAID WELL, NO, HE WAS
SIMPSON WOULDN'T ANSWER ANY
THE MEDIA.
HE KEPT STEPPING BACK.
HE WOULDN'T ANSWER IT.
THEN WE FIND OUT HE DIDN'T
EVEN VERIFY THE INFORMATION
IN THE DOSSIER.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT ALL OF,
THE DNC ACTUALLY PAID FOR
THIS, PAID FOR THIS DOSSIER
AND THAT THE DOSSIER ITSELF
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN BY
THE RUSSIANS CLEARLY THERE
IS A PROBLEM.
>> Sean: YOU MAKE A GOOD
POINT AS.
I'M A CONSERVATIVE, A PROUD
LOT THAT THE FIX WAS IN.
I WANT TO USE THIS ANALOGY,
THAT THE FIX WAS IN, POOR
BERNIE SANDERS AND HIS
SUPPORTERS, THEY HAD NO SHOT
AT ALL WHATSOEVER AND EVEN
DONNA BRAZILE ADMITS THAT
THEN HAVE YOU COMEY AND
STRZOK I DON'T BELIEVE I
HAVE EVER HEARD OF A CASE
WHERE YOU WRITE EXONERATION
INVOLVED IN AN
INVESTIGATION.
THEY DIDN'T DO THE
INVESTIGATION BUT THEY ARE
WRITING AN EXONERATION.
ARE TRYING TO PUT THE FIX IN
WE NOW LEARN AND THEN YOU
TAKE IT A STEP FURTHER, AND
THAT INFORMATION WAS PUT
BEFORE A FISA COURT AND A
WARRANT ISSUED.
AS A CONSTITUTIONAL SCHOLAR,
I HOPE YOU ARE AS AFRAID AS
I AM ABOUT THESE ISSUES,
ABOUT THE CORRUPT NATURE OF
ALL OF THIS AND THE -- AND
OUR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS IN
ABOUT THAT.
THAT'S WHY I CALLED FOR
RIGHT FROM THE BEGINNING AN
IMPARTIAL NONPARTISAN
COMMISSION OF INQUIRY TO
LOOK INTO EVERY ASPECT OF
THE LAST ELECTION.
EVERY ASPECT.
WHAT THE RUSSIANS TRIED TO
DO IN TERMS OF THE
REPUBLICANS.
THIS IS A BIPARTISAN ISSUE.
EVERY AMERICAN SUFFERS WHEN
THE RUSSIANS IN ANY WAY TRY
TO INFLUENCE THE ELECTION,
LOOK, I DON'T THINK THE
RUSSIANS TRIED TO INFLUENCE
THE ELECTION NECESSARILY IN
FAVOR OF ONE CANDIDATE OR
THE OTHER.
I THINK THEY TRIED INFLUENCE
THE ELECTION IN TERMS OF
DESTABILIZING THE AMERICAN
POLITICAL SYSTEM.
THAT'S WHY HAVING A SPECIAL
WE NEED AN OPEN
INVESTIGATION COMMISSION.
THIS IS TOO IMPORTANT TO ALL
>> LET ME FOLLOW UP WITH THE
DOSSIER, IT WAS PARTISAN,
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR,
REMEMBER, CHRISTOPHER STEELE
DIDN'T COME ON BOARD WITH
FUSION UNTIL HILLARY AND THE
DNC WERE PAYING FOR IT BUT
THAT DOSSIER USED TO OBTAIN
AT LEAST IN PART, MAYBE
SIGNIFICANTLY AS SARA IS
REPORTING, TO GET A FISA
WARRANT ON A OPPOSITION
CANDIDATE AND A
WARRANT WERE KNOWN TO BE
FALSE.
NOW, UNDER CASE CALLED
FRANKS VS. MARYLAND, IT'S
NOT ENOUGH UNDER THE FOURTH
AMENDMENT FOR IT TO BE
WRONG.
IT HAS TO BE KNOWN TO BE
AND SO, AGAIN, THIS SHOULD
BE LOOKED INTO, EVERY FACT
CAN I SAY ONE MORE THING?
I HAVE TO TELL YOU JUST ONE
MORE THING.
AMERICAN IMMIGRANTS WHO CAME
FROM A VERY, VERY POOR
COUNTRY IN EUROPE, I HOPE
THE PRESIDENT WILL APOLOGIZE
FOR WHATEVER HE SAID THAT
DEMEANS IMMIGRANTS.
THE STATUE OF LIBERTY SAYS
GIVE US YOUR POOR, YOUR
HUNGRY, PEOPLE YEARNING TO
BE FREE.
AND TRY NOT TO INSULT PEOPLE
FROM ANY PART OF THE WORLD
AND THE PRESIDENT CAN DO A
GREAT SERVICE IF HE JUST
COMES FORWARD AND SAYS.
>> Sean: DID HE ADMIT TODAY
HE USED TOUGH LANGUAGE BUT
HE DENIED -- WE WILL GET
INTO THIS LATER IN THE SHOW
HE DENIED WHAT DURBIN SAID,
SUNNY PERDUE AND ANOTHER
SENATOR IN THE ROOM SAID
THEY DIDN'T HEAR IT.
WE WILL GET TO THAT.
>> IT DOESN'T MUCH MATTER
WHAT WORDS HE USED.
I THINK IT WAS A THRUST
AGAINST CERTAIN COUNTRIES.
WE JUST CAN'T HAVE THAT KIND
OF ATTITUDE IT MAKES US LOOK
VERY BAD IN THE WORLD AND
REALLY UNDERCUTS WHAT OUR
STATUE OF LIBERTY HAS LONG
STOOD FOR.
>> Sean: SARA, BEFORE I GET
TO TOM, I WANT TO FOLLOW UP
ON SOMETHING PROFESSOR
DERSHOWITZ WAS SAYING, I
HAVE ONE SOURCE, I DON'T
HAVE TWO, THAT ACTUALLY TOLD
ME THAT THERE WAS ONE
CONFIRMATION AS IT RELATES
TO THE DOSSIER.
AND I WAS GIVEN A NAME.
AND IT HAPPENS TO BE
SOMEBODY THAT IS A CORRUPT
INDIVIDUAL INSIDE THE
CLINTON CIRCLES AND YOU
KNOW -- I CAN TELL BY YOUR
>> I KNOW EXACTLY HOW ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
IF THAT DOES COME TO
FRUITION, IF WE FIND OUT.
>> Sean: THEN THE COURT MAY
HAVE BEEN LIED.
>> TO THEN THE COURT MAY
HAVE BEEN LIED TO.
WHAT ALAN DERSHOWITZ SAID
WOULD DEFINITELY TAKE
SIGNIFICANCE.
>> Sean: TOM, TELL US WHAT
JUDICIAL WATCH IS DOING.
>> I THINK IT'S GOING TO BE,
AS SARA IS INDICATING A
TSUNAMI OF INFORMATION
COMING OUT ON THE SCANDALS.
THE COURT RULE THAT THE
CLINTON EMAILS NEED TO BE
RELEASED MORE QUICKLY.
ALL THESE CLINTON EMAILS SHE
TRIED TO HIDE DELETED.
>> Sean: WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANY
WEDDING, A FUNERAL.
EMAILING BILL WHO DOESN'T
EMAIL.
>> WE FOUND ON THE WIENER
WHICH I GUARANTEE YOU IS
GOING TO BE COMING OUT.
THEN WE HAD THE COURT JUST
YESTERDAY TALK ABOUT HOW HE
THE COMEY MEMOS WHICH ARE
THE GENESIS OF THE MURIEL
OPERATION THERE WOULD BE NO
MURIEL SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
BUT FOR THE LEAKING OF COMEY
TO THE "NEW YORK TIMES" ON
ONE SPECIFIC MEMO.
SO THAT MATERIAL MAY BE
COMING OUT.
IT'S ALL BUILDING.
AND THERE ARE TEXT MESSAGES
THAT ARE COMING OUT.
AS ED IS TALKING ABOUT, NOW
WE ARE GOING TO FIND OUT
MORE DETAILS ABOUT THE
FISA -- THE INTELLIGENCE
SURVEILLANCE ABUSES.
NOW, YOU KNOW MY CONCERN IS
WHY WITH ARE WE WAITING TO
FIND OUT ABOUT THEM AFTER
THE REAUTHORIZATION OCCURS?
I WOULD SUGGEST WE FIND OUT
ABOUT THE ABUSES BEFORE THEY
REAUTHORIZE THIS FOR ANOTHER
BECAUSE DEVON NUNEZ.
I WILL LET YOU REPORT ON
THIS.
THE FIGHT ACT WHICH IS
PROBABLY GOING TO PASS IS
GOING TO DISCLOSE WHAT
ACTUALLY EXTENSE ABUSES.
>> Sean: EXTENSIVE ABUSE.
>> IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND THE FBI.
I HAVE GOT IT TELL YOU THIS,
THIS IS COMING FROM PEOPLE
WITHIN THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY.
THIS SYSTEM HAS BEEN ABUSED.
HAVE SEEN, RIGHT?
WE KNOW FROM WHAT WE HAVE
SEEN THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
AN INVESTIGATION.
LET'S DO IT BEFORE.
>> Sean: PROFESSOR
DERSHOWITZ, WHAT DEVON NUNES
IS SAYING THAT THERE IS
CLEAR EVIDENCE OF MASSIVE
ABUSE OF GOVERNMENT
SURVEILLANCE BY THE FBI AND
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
OFFICIALS CIVIL LIBERTARIAN
FIRST AND FOREMOST, SIR.
>> CIVIL LIBERTARIANS,
LIBERALS AND CONSERVATIVES
ALIKE HAVE OKAY WORRIED
ABOUT THE FBI, ITS
SURVEILLANCE METHODS AND THE
POTENTIAL FOR ABUSE.
HE DIDN'T HAVE THE COURAGE
TO STAND UP IN FRONT OF A TV
CAMERA AND SAY THIS IS
INFORMATION THAT I'M GOING
APPOINTED.
HE LAUNDERED IT THROUGH A
COLUMBIA PROFESSOR.
THESE ARE ISSUES THAT SHOULD
BE INVESTIGATED.
WE HAVE TO KNOW WHAT
SURVEILLANCE IS BEING USED
AGAINST AMERICANS AND
WHETHER YOU ARE A
CONSERVATIVE OR A LIBERAL OR
A REPUBLICAN OR A DEMOCRAT,.
>> Sean: IT DOESN'T MATTER.
>> YOU SHOULD CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT ANY ABUSE OF THIS
PROCESS.
>> Sean: IF YOU BELIEVE IN
THE CONSTITUTION AND OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS, NOBLE
>> HILLARY CLINTON AND HER
TOP CAMPAIGN AIDS NEED TO BE
BROUGHT IN AT LEAST BY
CONGRESS TO TESTIFY ABOUT
WHAT THEY KNEW AND WHEN
ABOUT THIS DOSSIER.
GLENN SIMPSON REFUSED TO
TALK ABOUT WHETHER THE
CLINTON CAMPAIGN, HIS PAY
MASTER, WHAT THEIR
INVOLVEMENT WAS IN DIRECTING
CHRIS STEELE'S USE OF